this is el sante
known locally as bitcoin beach this
small salvadoran tourist town is home to
a variety of small businesses
whose owners all have one thing in
common cryptocurrency
tourists who didn't bring cash would
come and say they wanted to eat
something
and they asked if they could pay in
bitcoin i said to myself
this is a good strategy i'm going to use
bitcoin and i'm going to start
collecting
i downloaded the app and i started
selling a lot more
the success of the bitcoin beach project
has boosted the popularity of
cryptocurrency in el salvador
and on wednesday the government
announced bitcoin would become
legal tender therefore
the law of bitcoin is approved
supporters of the measure say the new
law represents a vote of confidence in
using blockchain technology
to bring informal sector workers into a
21st century economy
and the banks are not necessary this is
another important thing
there are many salvadorans in this
country that cannot use a bank
because they have thousands of
requirements el salvador now becomes the
first country in the world to formally
legalize a digital currency
the initiative was led by el salvador's
president naib bukele
on twitter he called the passing of the
bitcoin law historic
in the short term this will generate
jobs and help provide financial
inclusion to thousands outside the
formal economy
and in the medium and long term we hope
that this small decision can help us
push humanity at least a tiny bit
into the right direction there are also
critics who
warn of the risks of bitcoin price
fluctuations
the moment bitcoin becomes a legal
currency problems appear
including in its most basic use which is
a form of exchange
and this is related to the volatility of
the price of bitcoin
while some also warned that legalizing a
decentralized digital currency
could be wielded as a tool for
corruption bitcoin believers
in el sol and across el salvador say the
new law will only increase financial
inclusion
and has the potential to spur economic
development
manuel rapalo al jazeera